salut je m'appelle Guillaume dia je suis
danseur étoile à l'Opéra de Paris
[Musique]
c'est l'entrée des artistes
pour aller dans les lol moi je suis
encore dans les loges les loges avec
tout le monde
[Musique]
c'est pas encore pris possession de ta
loge particulière
alors là c'est vraiment le bordel mais
comme tu as pas idée
ah c'est grand
un peu partout j'essaye de me justifier
mais la petite photo avec ma sœur
qui me donne la force de l'inspiration
tous les jours de la même manière ou ça
dépend de ton état
ça dépend un peu de mon état là
aujourd'hui je vais un peu plus
m'échauffé parce que j'ai une grosse
journée et parce que je suis fatiguée le
plus sérieusement tu t'es chauffes le
moins tu as de risques de te blessé qui
est une grosse blessure l'année dernière
je me suis fait une fraction de fatigo
aussi bien en fait j'ai trop poussé
dessus et comme j'étais
cette formation elle était quand même
anxiogène dans le sens où je faisais des
rôles
de thé j'avais l'impression que je
pouvais pas laisser passer ma chance et
j'avais super mal et j'ai continué de
danser dessus jusqu'au point
j'arrive presque plus à marcher tu vois
la carrière d'un danseur elle est elle
est courte et on a toujours cette
pression de l'âge tu vois au dessus de
nous dire
mais si je sais pas si à 25 ans je suis
pas premier danseur au sujet ou s'il
faut que je sois absolument dans cette
étoile avant de 30 ans et tout ça et du
coup on a toujours ce truc un peu de
stress où on a toujours peur de
rater le bon moment tu vois ou de rater
sa chance
j'ai commencé la danse à quatre ans
parce que ma sœur en faisait je voulais
tout simplement la copier j'ai vraiment
commencé le classique à 8 ans ça m'a mis
du temps ça a vraiment conscientiser le
fait que être danseur ça pouvait être un
métier et que j'avais vraiment envie de
le faire c'était un de quand même très
scolaire tu vois j'ai mis les études
j'avais envie d'être médecin je suis
vraiment dit ok maintenant Guillaume tu
te donnes les moyens pour être danseur à
l'Opéra vers
15 ans je pense ça m'a fait du bien en
fait de pas être dans cette optique là
trop jeune parce que ça m'a préservé
aussi un peu et c'est grâce à mes
parents tu pourras me disait tout le
temps oui mais l'école c'est important
que tu aies des bonnes notes et tout
machin parce que tu sais pas ce qui peut
arriver et tout et du coup ça m'a permis
de
même si j'étais à l'école de l'Opéra tu
vois de garder la vraie raison pour
laquelle je vais danser c'est à dire
parce que ça me faisait plaisir et parce
que ça me permettait de m'exprimer Dieu
toi au début
spécial sur
[Musique]
ça a été nommé et toi mais en mars
dernier
il y a 3 mois maintenant et j'ai pas
l'impression d'avoir digéré encore
toutes les informations
qui viennent avec cette nomination
décrocher le titre d'étoiles c'est un
honneur c'est une pression
les deux les deux premiers ont soit
c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose dont
je suis fier tu es content que ça arrive
je suis content pour les générations
futures pour les enfants qui peuvent se
reconnaître en moi et qui ont ce que
finalement moi j'ai pas eu c'est en ça
que je trouve ça génial du jour au
lendemain j'ai reçu énormément d'amour
et malheureusement aussi beaucoup de
choses négatives et
ça m'a affecté mais j'essaie de
m'accrocher à l'amour et de me dire que
la meilleure façon de d'être le symbole
de ça d'être le premier danseur étoile
noire de l'Opéra c'est en dansant en
continuant d'être
qui je suis et de aller chercher à
changer parce que parce que je suis ça
maintenant